auch herzlich willkommen von meiner
seite es freut mich dass sie alle da
sind wir haben jetzt unsere erste
konstituierende fraktionssitzung der
fraktion dieser wahlperiode
wir haben unsere
vorläufige geschäftsordnung einmütigen
lawson und der bisherige
fraktionsvorstand ist einstimmig
kommissarisch im amt bestätigt worden
wir bereiten uns jetzt auf sondierungen
vor denn ganz entscheidend ist dass die
nächste bundesregierung eine
bundesregierung wird die die großen
probleme in diesem land angeht die nicht
kompromisse auf dem kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner schließt sondern
dafür sorgt dass dinge wie die
klimakrise die probleme in der
wirklichkeit sind dass wir uns da
gemeinsam darum bemühen die maßnahmen zu
finden um die gemeinsam beschlossenen
ziele des pariser klimaschutzabkommen
wirklich umzusetzen und wichtig ist dass
die gespräche auf augenhöhe und respekt
zwischen allen drei partnern stattfinden
ja sie haben mitbekommen dass diverse
gespräche geplant sind das ist auch gut
und richtig so die bundestagsfraktion
von bündnis 90/die grünen ist
entschieden sich auf den kurs von
sondierungen und hoffentlich auch
koalitionsgesprächen und dann eine
regierung zu begeben es ist ein klar
dass die probleme sehr sehr groß sind
die in diesem land und vor uns liegen
dass es um die frage der bewältigung der
klimakrise geht aber dass es natürlich
auch darum geht dass die gesellschaft
zusammen bleibt zwischen stadt und land
zwischen alt und jung das alles
beschäftigt uns jetzt sehr und es werden
inhaltliche vorbereitungen bereits
angefangen in diesen tagen und
gleichzeitig finden die gespräche statt
sie kennen alle die zusammensetzung von
teams sie wissen auch die daten von
gesprächen und zunächst mal ist es ja so
dass mit der fdp gesprochen worden es
wird mit der spd gesprochen
und dann schauen wir inwieweit die union
auch gesprächsfähig wird entsprechend
die gesprächsangebote hat es ja gegeben
[Musik]
es hat sich schon was geändert nämlich
dass verhandlungen intern stattfinden
und nicht in aller öffentlichkeit dass
keine fotos von papieren veröffentlicht
werden sondern wenn dann fotos von
menschen es sollte sich auf jeden fall
ändern und das sieht auch so aus dass
nicht sondierungsgespräche quasi schon
vorweggenommen
koalitionsverhandlungen sind dass beides
sollte klar sein muss klar sein und dass
das wesentliche ist dass man sich
vertraut dass man weiß was ist dem
jeweils anderen partner der anderen
partnerinnen in besonderer weise wichtig
und dass man sich auf dinge verlassen
kann und es gibt noch keinen termin für
die nächste woche das hat natürlich auch
damit zu tun dass es innerhalb der union
jetzt erstmal so ist das für ordnung
gesorgt werden muss sie haben ja gefragt
kommt das für uns überhaupt in frage wir
haben sehr deutlich gemacht wir sprechen
mit allen gleichwohl ist es so dass wir
davon ausgehen dass die übereinstimmung
mit der spd größer sind als mit anderen
und dass wir mit der fdp in einigen
bereichen die bürgerrechte sind
beispielsweise angesprochen worden
übereinstimmungen haben aber was am ende
dabei funktioniert und rauskommt das
kann man natürlich nicht am anfang sagen
ich meine
da sind es nochmal wesentlichen die
größten zugewinne
sorgen
aber
dessen haus bei der union keine basis
seien wirklich nicht in spanien zu
können sie sich auch glauben also bei
der fdp gibt es ja ganze reihe von
gemeinsamkeiten wenn man daran denkt
auch sie wollen dass die digitalisierung
endlich funktioniert die fdp ist sich
darüber bewusst dass wir eine
ausbildung brauchen in der fdp gibt es
gemeinsamkeiten zu den bürgerrechten
allerdings ist auch vollkommen bekannt
dass insbesondere bei steuern und
finanzierung unterschiedliche ansichten
gibt aber auch die fdp ist der meinung
dass wir mehr investitionen brauchen und
dann muss man darüber reden wie wir das
in den griff kriegt
das was hier und er muss muss die union
klären und wenn die dann wissen wer mit
wem reden kann dann wird das geschehen
ich hatte den eindruck in den letzten
tagen kann man nicht sagen da weiß man
mit dem man redet und wer die gruppe ist
mit der man spricht das kann sich ja
ändern es ist nicht unsere aufgabe sich
um die machtverhältnisse union zu
kümmern
dass wir versorgen auch mehr über
inhalte hören werden sagt der
maler china unserem zweiten gibt es denn
schon ein
spd und
wir werden über inhalte sprechen und wir
werden das vertrauensvoll tun
[Musik]
von dem
kleinen parteitag werden wir die
sondierungsgruppe einsetzen und wir
haben ja einen antrag beschließen und
beim antrag jetzt zentral darum dass wir
eine regierung brauchen die auf
augenhöhe mit den problemen kommt und
nicht immer nach dem kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner agiert und dafür
werden wir alles tun dafür ist die
partei dafür ist die fraktion betreibt
ja also das macht natürlich keinen sinn
dass man sagt wir müssen das jetzt in
zweieinhalb tagen hinbekommen haben aber
was glaube ich alle beteiligten wollen
mit denen wir inzwischen geredet haben
ist dass ich das nicht ewig lange
hinzieht insbesondere die sondierungen
nicht wir wollen möglichst schnelle
sanierung um rauszufinden kann etwas
werden und dann soll in die tiefe
verhandelt werden
dass wir das team und die arbeitsgruppen
jetzt doch auch die sondierung mit der
fdp gebildet worden sind aber täuscht
dieser eindruck oder ist doch so zu
sorgen die ausstellung die in jedem fall
jedes hat damit nichts zu tun das hat
damit zu tun wer die gremien sind die
idee erfahrungen mitbringen und das gut
organisieren können das hat jetzt nichts
mit der aufstellung in bezug auf einen
partner zu tun
wir halten ehrlich gesagt zu dem
zeitpunkt überhaupt nichts von
personalspekulationen in irgendeine
richtung es geht ja um die inhalte und
personal wird als gesamtpaket am ende
der verhandlungen entschieden
[Musik]
sängerin
das muss die union jetzt wirklich selber
klären und dann muss sie sagen wir sind
die leute und wer hat das vertrauen das
gesamt das ist aber wirklich nicht
unsere aufgabe und was die diversität
angeht ja richtig das hat schlicht damit
zu tun dass wir uns auf die strukturen
die wir haben dabei berufen haben und
dass wir da handlungsbedarf haben das
sehen sie am vielfalt statut der partei
das sehen sie daran dass sich die
bundestagsfraktion damit beschäftigt hat
den boden fahren
akzeptiert
sorry aber die man laut stellen gar
nicht weitergeben das verbunden
es gilt dieses klar für das
personalproblem der union ist erstmal
die union zuständig und wenn die union
sich entschieden hat dann kommentieren
wir das aber jetzt rum zu spekulieren
macht in unseren augen überhaupt keinen
sinn
die
gespräche sind ja dafür da dass man
gespräche führt und dass man offen
reingeht und dass man nicht sagt dann
haben wir einen plan das ist weiß ich
für sie ein bisschen unbefriedigend aber
genau das ist die art und weise wie wir
diese gespräche gerne führen wollen
nämlich auf augenhöhe und in dieser
konstellation haben wir uns auch noch
nicht getroffen mit der fdp und deswegen
tun wir das in aller offenheit und alles
andere werden sie dann sicher erfahren
[Musik]
also dann ich glaube es ist so geplant
dass von uns zehn kommen und von der fdp
9 oder 10
das sondierungsteam daran teil
[Musik]
das hat der bundesvorstand beschlossen
und der länder hat ist die zeit erst
danach aber das hat der bundesvorstand
beschlossen ist sicher ob wir einfach so
frei floaten entstanden und der länder
hat er noch ein paar mehr sachen machen
zum beispiel den antrag beschützen
nein es geht um das sondierungsteam das
auf dem parteitag beschlossen wird
deshalb der bundesvorstand beschlossen
der aus dem gremium der partei und
selbstverständlich ist theoretisch
möglich dass was geändert wird aber wir
sind auch sehr optimistisch dass der
kleine parteitag des sondierungsteams so
bestätigen wird wie es der
bundesvorstand beschlossen hat
preis gute
ja soweit also die fraktionsvorsitzenden
der grünen nach ihrer sitzung mit sehr
vorsichtigen äußerungen zu dem was
kommen wird und wie es weitergehen
könnte wir entschuldigen uns dass wir
die dokumentation davor abbrechen
mussten aber wir wollen sie natürlich
über alles was in berlin derzeit
passiert was ja alles spannend ist immer
auf dem laufenden halten und machen
jetzt weiter mit der dokumentation wege
zur macht
anstieg des meeresspiegels mehr
hitzewellen dürren und starkregen
unglaubliche szenen die sich heute am
internationalen flughafen